[Music]
in a world going to its second Stephen
King asan's
the sequel to the highest-grossing
horror film is here and the scariest
part is the runtime 250 not real real it
chapter 2 the losers Club is all grown
up half of them are big celebrities but
all of them are still losers bills and
author who writes crappy endings in a
nod to both Stephen King and the movie
you're watching on assignment for yeah I
didn't like the end and get it Ben is
hung up on his middle school crush
middle school dude
Ritchie somehow makes Bill Hader unfunny
beverley married her dad and Eddie
literally married his mother am I
thought this took place in Maine not the
front page of Alabama pornhub Mike will
summon these super friends to help him
capture three big space balls who takes
the form of Pennywise a shape-shifting
cloud who could kill them at anytime but
doesn't and settles for either spooky
balloons or passive-aggressive roommate
notes because it turns out Pennywise
kind of sucks at monster stuff what kind
of ancient horror gets an egg to death
you drilled at the first film a slick
adaptation of the novel that cut the
fluff and focused on ten scenes of kids
in danger now get ready for a faithful
adaptation of part two of the TV
mini-series Oh pumped up with action
that feels like it's missing video game
QuickTime events
[Music]
[Applause]
and so many shenanigans it won't just
break the tension
it'll deflate it like a sad clowns penis
[Music]
that's a good boy as you sit through a
movie that keeps expanding like it's
trying to fill a 13-episode Netflix
order this is stupid
we already remember everything full of
side quests that don't end up mattering
a Native American ritual that doesn't
even summon a cosmic turtle and an
hour's worth of it chapter one deleted
scenes hey you guys remember that one
summer when we all got digitally de-aged
that was the best let's stay friends
forever so buckle up for the second and
final chapter of it a film that's almost
guaranteed to be the last sequel because
all the prime locations and villains
disintegrate but that doesn't mean there
won't be more spin-offs
he's been active every 27 years for how
long again just a few story killer Klown
from outer space open-mouthed School of
Acting insane in the chest Dane Jerry
O'Connell the man your man could shove
like Jerry's hottest club is the losers
clubhouse this place has everything
balloons shower caps street fighter on
an open sewer plus you can do a human
bunion that's a thing the statue of Paul
Bunyan comes to life and chases you
she's my mother my wife my mother she's
my mother and my wife spider head spider
head he's taunting you because your
friend is dead my knife and Dean Koons
it stinks
here's Johnny wait
so the shiny exist in this universe so
does Stephen King also exist does he
hate the movie adaptation and does that
make this place a good cook a good
go shop songs 1% battery left get to the
charger this is the way bow to baby Yoda
uh may the Schwartz be with you so raise
your glass then break the glass then
stomp your bare feet on the glass
where's the lime sauce